[MUSIC PLAYING]
DOUGLAS ECK: It's almost a full
room at 2:30 in the afternoon
on a Friday, so that's awesome.
My name's Doug.
I'm going to talk to you
about Magenta, a project
that we're doing in Google Brain
that's focused on music and art
with machine learning.
So I hope there
are some questions.
I'll try to blaze through this
and leave a little bit of time
for questions at the end.
I'm going to talk about two
different projects, both
of them under the
umbrella of Magenta.
One has to do with drawing,
and one has to do with sound.
But I want to give a little
idea, first, what Magenta is
and why we're doing
what we're doing.
Fundamentally, we're
asking the question,
can we use deep learning
and reinforcement learning
to do something creative.
And by this, I really mean
furthering our own creativity
as people.
I don't mean pushing a button,
and standing back, and watching
the computer make art.
I think that's less
interesting than actually
having a cool new piece of
technology to work with.
There are two things that
we're doing concretely.
One of them is an open
source project on GitHub.
It's part of TensorFlow,
TensorFlow Magenta.
And we're trying to
engage a number of people
to work with us, all
of you in the room,
including creative coders,
including musicians, including
artists, and
including developers.
And at the same time,
it's a research effort.
So part of our mission in
Google Brain on the Brain team
is to publish papers and
to work with academics.
And we're pushing all the stuff
out, not only at open source,
but in the research world.
We have a blog.
If you want to remember one URL,
it's magenta.tensorflow.org.
It's also at g.co/magenta, but
it's fine to do it this way.
And that'll link you to our
code and to other things.
So please check it out.
Now, there are a
number questions
you can ask about creativity,
and about art, and about music,
and how they all work together.
I've thought about
this problem a lot.
And I've come to the
conclusion that there's
a role that technology
plays, and there's
a role that artists
play, and that we
need to really carefully
understand that interaction.
Also, I want to point out
that this has been true
since we've been doing art.
A cave painting requires
a piece of charcoal.
Musical instruments are highly
evolved pieces of technology.
And so I think of us at
Magenta more like the person
on the left, who's Les Paul,
one of the people credited
with creating the
electric guitar,
and less like the
people on the right.
That's St. Vincent.
But you can think
of Jimi Hendrix.
You can think of
any artist who's
pushing the boundaries
of the electric guitar.
And I bring this
up because I think
it's important to
understand what people
do with technology and art.
They push it.
They drive it.
They break it.
Jimi Hendrix came along and
made the guitar distort.
Maybe some of you in
the crowd are aware,
but the goal of
the electric guitar
was to create a loud
acoustic guitar.
And distortion of the
amplifier was a failure case.
In the engineering world,
it was a fall over.
Yet people come along-- this
is true for film cameras
as well too, overexposing film.
Any piece of technology
you think of,
you're going to find
people breaking it as part
of the artistic process.
And I love that.
So for me, success
for Magenta would
be if someone does something
in five years with what
we built that we had no idea
was coming, none whatsoever.
So I want you to
have that in mind,
that what we're thinking
about is furthering
the creative process
like all technology that
came before that's
used artistically.
Very quick tour, given the
time we have, is deep learning.
Deep learning is deep.
See how deep the stack is.
Weighted connections
in a neural network
are being trained in order
to predict something.
It's also worth noting
that these models naturally
extract nice features,
nice filters from data,
making it possible
for us to focus
on the use of machine learning
for creative processes.
So we don't have to
build these things in.
By the way, this slide is great.
It's from Zeiler and Fergus,
a great research paper
from about five years ago.
I also want to point out,
for those of you that
are paying attention
to deep learning,
deep learning, in some
sense, is not new.
We've had neural networks since
at least the 1980s, arguably
the 1960s.
But they haven't always shown
themselves to be the most--
you know, the best
models for the job.
One explanation for this
is that neural networks
are really good at scale.
They're really good when
you have a lot of data
or when you have large models.
And so as we move with more
compute power, what we find
is that neural networks
end up winning out
over other technologies, which
I think is, in its own right,
interesting and worthy of
discussion, but not here,
because we have to move on.
All right, let's jump
into our first project.
This project was led by David
Ha, a Google Brain resident,
extremely creative guy.
And this project is about
teaching a machine learning
model to learn to draw.
And these are some
of the pictures
that this machine
learning model drew.
Just a show of hands,
how many people
have seen the Sketch-RNN stuff
or are familiar with the Quick
Draw data.
All right, that's great.
OK, so we're going to see
a little bit more of that.
Some of the Quick Draw guys
are sitting right over here
if you want to give them
a shout out for the game
and for the data.
Awesome work.
[APPLAUSE]
On our part, in Magenta, we
trained models on Quick Draw.
And we just released a
bunch of source code.
And you can train
your own models.
We even have a nice
Jupyter Notebook.
The call to action there is to
go to magenta.tensorflow.org.
Jump into our blog.
You'll find the blog posting.
It's easy enough
to find our GitHub.
And you can play around.
You can decide--
like we did here,
you can draw some flamingos
in, like, three lines of code.
And it's kind of fun to do.
So please check that out
and give us feedback.
I want to talk a little bit
about the machine learning
in this project.
Fundamentally, what
we're working with
are a kind of machine
learning technology
called an autoencoder.
And there's a couple
of basic ideas
that I want everybody
to understand.
What we're doing is
we're taking some input--
in this case, it's strokes as
drawn by someone on a screen--
and we're building some
sort of neural network
that can encode them into
some other representation.
And in general,
that representation
is not larger, but smaller
than the source representation.
So the model is forced
to try to pull out
the important
regularities in the data,
because it's not big enough
to memorize the data.
And so that Z in
the middle, think
of that as your reduced
representation that
has pulled out all the
important bits that it
needs to try to recreate these.
And it's going to drive a
decoder to recreate the output.
In our case, the input
are stroke-based drawings
done by people when they
play the game, Quick Draw.
And we encode them using a
recurrent neural network that
is actually moving through
the sequence of strokes,
trying to predict
the next stroke,
and actually moving backwards
from the end sequence,
trying to predict the
sequences in reverse order.
It's called a bi-directional
recurrent neural network
or a bi-directional LSTM.
And the whole job
of that network
is to create this vector,
the Z I was talking about,
or if you're Canadian, Zed.
And this vector is going to be
used to condition the decoding.
So we have this
embedding, this number,
the string of numbers in latent
space that we can sample from,
that we can add some
noise to and generate
new instances of data.
That will then be driven
through the decoder, which
is, in this case, another
recurrent neural network,
though only going in one
direction, from left to right.
And it's going to drive
a mixture of Gaussians,
so a mixture of possible places
where the pen would land next.
And if, for some of you, that's
word salad, that's great.
It's fun word salad.
And if some of you
understand it better,
jump off and read our paper.
You can grab the paper
from tensorflow--
magenta.tensorflow.org.
So the most important
thing in machine learning
is having data.
And the Quick draw team, A,
designed a brilliant game.
Thanks to Jonas, who's
sitting over there,
and the rest of the
people in Creative Lab
for drawing a really fun game
to play along with, and also,
for releasing the data for
machine learning researchers
to work with, and also for
you to play with and enjoy.
So everything that we
did in this project
relies on having that
data and running that data
through generative models.
I also want to give a shout
out to a related project
from the handwriting
team, AutoDraw,
which is doing, in some
sense, the reverse of what
we're trying to do.
We're trying to
generate new drawings.
This one is trying
to take your drawing
and find the nearest
matching icon or some nearest
matching drawing done
by a professional.
So it's another really cool
thing that you can try.
Just hit autodraw.com.
Now I want to do a demo.
So can we switch over
to this demo screen?
This demo was built by David.
And what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to draw something on the left.
And then we're going to sample
from the model nine times.
And remember, the model
has some noise in it.
It's not completely
deterministic,
so we're going to get
nine different drawings.
This is a model that's
trained on rain.
And so let's take and just
draw a raindrop, all right?
You'll see my raindrop
appearing nine times.
And I did a nice,
big, round raindrop.
And now I'm going
to let the model go.
And it's going to
make rain happen.
And you can see
some of the variety,
the kind of natural
variety in the model
that comes from sampling
from it multiple times.
You could also just say, hey,
let's draw rain like this.
Because some people
draw rain like this.
And notice the model
kind of follows my lead.
And it draws rain
like I did, right?
Or-- and this is my favorite.
When David did this for me,
I thought it was pretty cool.
If you draw a cloud,
right, in your mind's eye,
what's going to happen
when I let that cloud go?
It's going to rain, right?
I just think that's so cool.
[APPLAUSE]
And I also like some of the
more complicated drawings.
Like, I actually don't know
how to draw a cruise ship.
I've never actually been on
a cruise ship, I don't think.
And I don't want food poisoning.
And there's-- so
I'll just do that.
And then Quick Draw will fill
it in with different kinds
of cruise ships-- or
Sketch-RNN based on Quick Draw.
So that's kind of fun too.
And finally, let's do one more.
It's fun to use that
time on these demos.
We can't leave without a cat.
And so I'm going to show you
what this temperature dial does
down here.
We're sampling from this model.
So we have this
Zed, and we're going
to use a little bit of math
to draw a new version of Zed
and then generate from it.
And we can actually
change a parameter
that makes the drawings follow
lower probabilities instead
of higher probabilities.
So we can kind of flatten
out the probabilities.
And that makes it seem like the
temperature's been turned up,
like it's a little hotter.
It's a little bit
less predictable.
So if I draw--
at low temperature, if
I draw my best cat--
I'll just give
myself two cat ears--
the model should draw some
nice, round cat faces,
and maybe even draw some
whiskers if we're lucky.
Yeah, you're kind of getting
archetypical cats there
at low temperature.
Now, I can control this
with this temperature
and turn it up a little bit.
And we'll start to see the
cat looking a little bit
less round.
So that looks like the cat that
I draw, the one in the middle.
I was always given-- you
know, like at art time,
they were sending you off
to play with the piano
or something like that.
This is not my area.
OK, can we switch back
to the slides, please?
That's the demo for Sketch-RNN.
It's also fun just to see
samples from this model.
Here we sampled
unconditionally, just
drew samples from the model
at different temperatures.
So is the color
of the icons get--
as the color of the
art gets more red,
that indicates that it's
sampled at a higher, kind
of crazier temperature.
And even in these fast talks,
it's fun to just kind of look
at this art.
The low temperature
ones, I think,
are really nice, simple views
of how people draw yoga.
You can actually try to recreate
some of these if you want,
and probably get away with it.
But don't try the high
temperature ones at home.
Hot yoga is dangerous.
I mean, they're just
really funny to look at.
So it's fun to sample from
the model unconditionally,
and it's also fun to do
conditional generation.
This is very different.
Now what we're doing is
we're taking a drawing--
those four drawings on the
left were done by David.
And we ran them through
the model and decoded them.
So you see, on the right,
the reconstructions.
But we remembered the Zeds
in the middle, the Zs,
out latent space.
And now we can just interpolate
through our latent space
and generate drawings
for all of the spaces
that we don't know about.
And I think it's quite good
the way the model moves
from these different shapes.
So each of those reconstructions
are in the corners.
And the color is following
the color mapping
between those colors.
And you get an
idea that the model
has a nice, smooth
representation
of how faces are drawn.
Also, I want to point
out that the model is not
memorizing data.
We purposely restrict the
size of the representation
to force it to generalize, and
we had a little bit of noise.
And I think this is cool.
It's a benefit.
So for example, if you
look on the left-hand side,
the human drawings
that are basically
good examples of the
class cat are more or less
reproduced by the model.
On the right, we drew
an eight-legged pig,
which is reconstructed
as a four-legged pig.
Because that's what the
model knows about pigs.
It knows that pigs
have four legs--
before you call me
out for some version
of "nose," for some version of
"pigs," and for some version
of "four legs."
Also, if you draw a truck
and pass it through the pig
classifier, you get kind of
a pig truck, which I think
is really cool.
Like, if you were asked
to draw a pig truck,
could you do a
better job than that?
That's really good, right?
Three-eyed cats,
they don't exist.
There's no chakra for our cats.
And if you do something like
run a toothbrush through the cat
classifier, you don't get a cat.
You don't get a toothbrush.
You kind of get gibberish.
So the model really is honing
in on something about drawing.
So that's a lot of fun.
I foresee a lot of possible
creative applications
of this going forward.
Lovely if people want
to hack our code.
Oh, this is the last thing.
If you're into math,
if you're math geek,
just look at this formula.
Do the algebra.
This is math done
on the embeddings.
I'm not even going
to explain it.
Just look at it.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah, wait long
enough, they applaud.
It's pretty cool, right?
So I love the idea that
the space is well enough
conditioned that
you can actually
move around numerically
in the space
and get meaningful results.
You can build pig heads from
pig bodies and subtractions
of cat heads and cat
bodies, et cetera.
No pigs were harmed.
OK, I'm going to move on
to project number two.
Project number two
is called NSynth.
We also released this this
week, or some part of it.
And what we wanted to do was
learn a music synthesizer.
We wanted to actually make
new sounds and sounds that
have captured some of
the underlying richness
and variance of musical
sounds that we work
with all the time as musicians.
People have been
doing this forever.
We're certainly not the only
use of software to make sounds.
Here's an analog synthesizer--
lots of knobs, fun to play with.
We're trying to do
is use deep learning
and see if we can get
a particular feeling
and a particular
interpretability to the sounds
that we're making.
This work also, I want
to point out, is really,
I thought, a great collaboration
between the Deep Mind
team in London and the
Brain team in Mountain View.
Sandra Dieleman was one of the
authors on the original WaveNet
paper, which I'll talk
about in a second.
He was a fantastic
collaborator with us.
And this project would not
have happened without it.
And I love that kind
of cross-collaboration.
So in terms of what you can
learn outside of this talk,
we have two postings on our
blog at magenta.tensorflow.org
that point to this really
wonderful AI experiment that
came from Creative
Lab that I'm going
to show you in a few minutes.
And we also-- for those of you--
all right, show of hands, who
knows what Ableton Live is?
All right, all of
you might consider
going to our open
source and downloading
the plugin for Ableton Live.
And you can drive your own
music with these samples.
It's fun.
It's cool.
So give that a look.
All right, so
first, to understand
what we're trying to do,
let's look back at the paper
from last year called WaveNet.
It's a paper that's
trying to learn
to generate audio from audio.
It's actually learning on the
raw PCM, Pulse-Code Modulation,
the raw speaker cone position
sampled 16,000 times a second.
And it's trying to predict
the next sample conditioned
on about the last two
seconds of samples.
And what it uses is something
called dilated convolution.
So you see the arrows.
They get spread further
and further apart.
It's almost like they're
being dilated in time so
that the next prediction
is conditioned
not only on the
sample that came last,
but some samples, or some
representations of samples,
that happened further
and further in the past.
And this allows WaveNet to be
able to make predictions that
have a little bit of coherence.
However there are some
limitations to this coherence.
Because the model
doesn't have anything
to condition it to allow
it to be more stable,
it really has a hard
time doing something
that is coherent over
more than about maybe
a fourth to a half of a second.
So let's play Dizzy, please.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The model's learning to
play Dizzy Gillespie trained
on Dizzy Gillespie only and
get something out of it.
Let's play Metallica.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And then, in the
bottom, we trained
on individual musical notes
from a data set that we released
in open source called NSynth.
The whole project's
called NSynth,
and so is the data set, because
we wanted to confuse everybody.
And so the model sees only
individual musical notes.
And if it's trained--
if a WaveNet is
trained on this data,
it's not quite capable of
producing a single note.
It wanders around.
So please play the second one.
[HIGH SUSTAINED NOTE]
It's definitely learning
about harmonics.
Let's go ahead and
play the first one too.
It's fun.
[LOW NOTE]
[DEEP BASS]
I like that bass.
So what we see is that the
NSynth data trained on WaveNet
alone does some cool things.
But it doesn't give
us our desired goal,
which is to have
coherent musical notes.
So what we decided to do
was add an autoencoder
to WaveNet so that we
can constrain and help
it understand how sound
is unfolding in time.
So this basic diagram
should look familiar.
You have some input.
Now it's not a cat or a
pig, it's an input waveform.
We're going to
encode that in time
using a kind of convolutional
model that's not a WaveNet
but is also using deep
dilated convolutions.
That's going to give us
some sort of embedding.
And in this case, the embedding
actually unfolds in time.
So it's 16 values that change
every few milliseconds.
And then, we're going
to have a WaveNet
decoder, the same
WaveNet that we just saw.
And the WaveNet
is actually going
to have the input audio
available when it's training.
But it's also going to see
this conditioning information
from our Zed.
And if it wants to take
advantage of it, it can.
And in fact, it does,
to great effect.
So now what we can do is
encode an entire note,
and we can then decode from it.
So let's listen to
the original bass.
[BASS NOTE]
Now, if we run that
bass through our model
and decode it in
the same way that we
ran the cat through our
model and looked at the cat,
it sounds like the
bass on the bottom.
[BASS NOTE]
So it's hard to hear
with the fan noise.
It's a little bit distorted.
Sometimes we get clicks.
But more or less, it captures
the sound of the bass.
Now let's hear the
original flute.
[FLUTE NOTE]
And now let's hear
the WaveNet flute.
[FLUTE NOTE]
So it's close.
So now you're
asking, why would you
want to reconstruct noisy
versions of these samples?
Because now, because we're
living in this embedding space,
we have this reduced
representation,
we can do exactly what we did
with the images of the cats
or the images of the people.
We can move between
sounds we know and listen
to what the model does in
spaces that we don't know.
So let's listen to what bass
and flute sounds like, original.
[BASS AND FLUTE]
It sounds like a bass
and a flute, right?
That's what the average is.
You just average the
signals together.
Now let's listen to bass
and flute from NSynth.
[BASS AND FLUTE]
Let's play that again.
I invite you to go to our blog
and listen to the examples
there with headphones.
But what it does,
in my mind's eye,
is makes a really big
bass flute, right?
Like physically, that's
what it sounds like.
In the interest of
time, let's just
go ahead and play
flute plus organ.
[FLUTE AND ORGAN]
I think even without hearing
the organ, you kind of get it.
And let's hear flute
plus organ from NSynth.
[FLUTE AND ORGAN]
Again, it kind of
grabbed the flute sound
and modulated it with
an organ-like sound.
I'm going to move on from these
now, in the interest of time.
These are what the
embeddings look like.
So I told you these are
temporal embeddings.
They actually unfold in time.
And there are 16 of
them, so we gave each one
a different color.
And then, now, we're looking
at bass, glockenspiel,
and flugelhorn, column-wise.
And you're seeing
the original waveform
shown in a kind of special
spectral reputation
where time unfolds
left to right.
And then, you're
seeing the embeddings
that were used to generate
the reconstructions.
I wanted just to give
you this basic idea
that what we're really providing
are those embeddings, those 16
values changing over time.
And then, the
WaveNet is learning
how to take advantage of them.
Now, let's go to--
I'm going to go to-- please
switch to the demo again, demo
computer, please.
OK, so the Creative
Lab team also
just released this
NSynth music instrument.
You can play with it online.
We have a link to
it from our blog.
You can also get at it--
oh, I'm sorry, what I
see up on the screen
is our internal link.
You'll find it from our blog.
It's easy to find.
Look for NSynth Sound Maker.
And here, you can play
with this yourself.
So--
[PLAYING NOTES]
--that's our bass
reconstruction.
Compare that to the original
upright bass by clicking here.
[UPRIGHT BASS]
And here's a clarinet.
[CLARINET]
And then, we can move
through the space and--
[PLAYING NOTES]
--we can sit in areas
that are blending
the clarinet and the bass in,
I think, interesting ways.
They're not all
beautiful, but they're
all kind of interesting.
[PLAYING NOTES]
We can try different samples.
I love this interface.
Again, cheers to the
Creative Lab team.
[GOOSE]
[COW]
We can do a cow.
[THUNDER]
I didn't mean to move past cow.
Who would want to do that?
So we have a cow.
Let's do a vibraphone cow.
So here's our cow.
[COW]
Right?
There's our cow.
[COW]
Yeah, you're
clapping, aren't you?
Because you know this is why--
they pay us to do this work.
I just want to point that
out, that we get paid.
[APPLAUSE]
[PLAYING NOTES]
And now we bring
the vibraphone in.
And we've actually got a really
interesting sound, right?
Like, it's getting it's
pitchiness from the vibraphone,
but it's totally
modulated by cow.
So you have this cow modulator.
So I invite you to lose--
if you have an auditory
system that works at all,
I promise you, you
can lose easily
an hour by just throwing
on a set of headphones
and playing around with this,
unless you're "Hacker News."
And then, you're negative about
everything, but that's OK.
Let's go back to the
slides again, please.
We also released a data
set for those of you
that want of your machine
learning yourself.
We have about 300,000
individual instrument sounds
that we generated from different
sample packs everywhere.
And we also released
them in a format
that has a bunch of the
metadata attached to it.
So you can know
what the genre was,
some of the note-like qualities
like bright, and dark,
and multiphonic.
And so this opens the
door for doing things
like training conditional
models, models that
know about these values,
so you can use them
to condition your generation.
You can use these for
anything you want to.
Add it's out there
and open source.
And we hope that it
fuels more research
in music-related deep learning.
I want to close now and have
plenty of time for questions.
I'm in love with this quote.
Who's heard of Brian Eno?
If you didn't raise your hand.
Homework-- go learn about
Brain Eno, fantastic musician.
And I just think this
captures what we're
trying to do with Magenta.
I like it so much that I'm
actually going to read it.
"Whatever you now find weird,
ugly, uncomfortable, and nasty
about a new medium will
surely become its signature.
CD distortion, the
jitteriness of digital video,
the crap sound of 8-bit--
the distorted guitar sound
is the sound of something
too loud for the medium
supposed to carry it."
And I love that thought.
I love the idea of trying
to build a new medium
with the understanding
that it's a medium that's
meant to be broken.
Like, we want
artists and musicians
to try to break these things, to
try to do new things with them.
And I think that's a really
wonderful interaction
between technology and art.
And it's one that I think
is just, A, it's fun, and B,
it's cool, right?
I don't know what
to say, all right?
So there's your
quote to close with.
Here's my call to action.
What can you do?
Have a look at TensorFlow,
magenta.tensorflow.org.
There's our blog.
There's our data,
discussion lists in GitHub.
You'll also find links
off to the great work
by Creative Lab, including
links to the data sets.
Or you just look on Reddit,
and you'll find them there.
And now, I managed to actually
save some time for questions.
So I hope you have questions.
I'm going to stop here.
And I thank you very much for
your attention on a hot Friday
afternoon.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]